the fact is is that we're on a good path
at the border under leadership of joe
biden president biden
we were in a very bad situation under
the trump administration
well the kids aren't on a good path
nancy pelosi giving a rosy assessment of
the border but the facts tell a
different story
a record number of unaccompanied migrant
children crossed the border in march
plus overall encounters are up 71
percent
and texas governor greg abbott is
calling on the biden administration to
close a migrant facility
over allegations of child abuse this
facility
is a health and safety nightmare
the body administration is now presiding
over the abuse
of children to end this abuse
the biden administration must
immediately
shut down this facility
so dana uh you know
that that's a really grim report and i'm
wondering how will the democrats come up
with a new way to describe it the way
they always tend to be able to describe
brutal things with interesting language
what could they call sexual assaults
looking at that chart i was thinking
reminded of the hockey stick do you
remember that the whole like climate
change thing
that's an actual hockey stick for you
right there the only good path
that is being beaten right now is the
one that the cartels have
made over the border and it reminds me
of when
uh the press secretary jensocki was
asked is this a crisis
and she said no and then she talked
about the challenge um well
again i think at that time you could
have said there's been a crisis there
for many
decades we're working on it etc now
we're
six weeks later and we've seen all of
these stories and
i think the speaker looks extremely out
of touch um
i don't think that there's a good path
and one of the reasons is it's not just
that they have a
a serious problem on their hands in
terms of the numbers that are coming
over
they're not doing anything to change the
trajectory yeah they're like literally
nothing they're not i know that
secretary marcus went down and visited
today perhaps then we'll see some sort
of policy change out of that but
that's what i think is really strange
like how could you call it a good path
when there's no change
but that's okay just follow up with that
why do you think
there because i think i mentioned this
yesterday you feel like there's
there has to be a strategy behind their
inaction right
no are you asking me yes
i don't know i g you you have to think
that there has to be something i mean
yeah these are not people that are
ignorant right i'm
i'm assuming that everybody realizes
this is going on
i know that they'd like to change the
subject and talk about the other things
like infrastructure and
covid and gun control or whatever else
of energy
um changing the definition of
infrastructure is there a strategy here
i mean
yeah i don't i don't think you should
confuse this with anything but
incompetence yeah that's
i i keep thinking i don't know will i
always feel like there's a strategy
behind
everything they do or this could be like
a new disorder
they just went from trump derangement to
uh border
chaos denialism you know i've become
fascinated with this question of what
was the intended outcome of the border
crisis because one thing i think we can
say with some certainty is it was
entirely predictable
i was just at the border and a chief
border patrol officer down there told me
you put policies like this in place you
knew what would happen it was entirely
predictable
so then that brings you well if it's
entirely predictable was it
intended now listening to nancy pelosi
right there you'd almost have to come
away with that conclusion and here's why
she said
we're on a very bad path with trump well
what was that bad path
there was a border wall being built
detentions were down because crossings
were down
now she said we're coming along what's
coming along as dana point out a hockey
stick
graph of encounters at the border in 19
000 migrant kids and
not detention centers but reception
facilities so if we're on a good path
now and we're on a bad path before are
we getting the intended outcome and
maybe
maybe it's not you know super
machiavellian like we're trying to
cultivate democratic voters maybe it's
just we want to be really empathetic
and we're trying to be humanitarian but
oops our intentions led to
like all intentions are road paved to
hell i don't know
what the intentions were but we have to
start asking was this part of the
intentions yeah it's weird
in one i mean just saw a number we're
spending 60 million per week to house
uh these miners and i keep thinking
about as i walk around new york
imagine how that money could help the
people here that are going
that are dealing with mental health
issues and drug abuse and
it our country is not in a great state
and now we're as
we're we're handicapping ourselves with
something like this
well greg you were saying there was
inaction obviously even just
saying we're spending money there would
suggest that we are taking action
hockey stick those 70 the 70 000
encounters boy it sounds to me like
we've got very
active border enforcement taking place
people being arrested and people being
expelled i mean that's an
answer to anybody who's you know buying
and biting down on the lie that we don't
have
a border and that somehow democrats want
open borders because they're showing up
juan
that's why there are more i think
no it's that we are more active and
there are more people showing up but the
real increases in terms of those kids
and again
contrary to what you're saying about no
action there's a lot of good news there
was good news today indicating
there's faster processing of those kids
they're spending less time now
either in the reception facilities or in
the housing while they're being
processed and get
get them out of here we can make
decisions get them
re united with their families or
relatives
that's what we can do homeland security
majorcas is down that went down to the
border today
susan rice has been down there vice
president harris has been talking with
these latin countries reversing
trump policy about offering support so
that people don't leave
because of desperation don't leave or
send their children
from those latin countries these are all
good
policies about people trying to solve
problems
not just mock each other i think that's
beautiful solving the problems you
create so the good news is kennedy
that the administration is acting faster
on cleaning up the mess
that they created there's your good news
and don't worry about the sex assaults
that happened you know part of the
messaging is if you send your kids we
won't send them back
if you're a dreamer we'll give you
citizenship that guarantees that you're
going to have more and more kids uh
crushing the border don't forget in this
facility at the freeman center
in san antonio the reason greg abbott
was so upset
is because there are kids who are being
underfed
it is understaffed you have kids who are
being kept
who are coveted positive with healthy
kids and you have
allegations of sexual abuse so that is
not a good path and anyone who says that
that is a good path
and we don't know about the number of
people who are getting over the border
we only know about the apprehensions we
don't know about the kids who are
possibly being abused in other detention
facilities they're not reception centers
when your life is being ruined i'm sorry
all right
up next